do you think we're living in a
simulation yes well so okay so I'm gonna
jump around from the absurdly
philosophical to the sure sure very very
happy to so I think uh my answer to that
question is a little bit complex because
uh there is simulation Theory which
obviously Nick Bostrom I think famously
first proposed
um and uh I don't quite believe it in in
that sense so
um in the in the sense that uh are we in
some sort of computer game or have our
descendants somehow recreated uh uh
Earth in the you know 21st century and
and some for some kind of experimental
reason I think that
um but I do think that we that that we
might be that the best way to understand
physics and the universe is from a
computational perspective so
understanding it as an information
universe and actually information being
the most fundamental unit of uh uh
reality rather than matter or energy so
a physicist would say you know matter
when energy you know E equals m c
squared these are the things that are
are the fundamentals of the universe I'd
actually say information
um which of course itself can be can
specify energy or matter right matter is
actually just you know we're we're just
out the way our bodies and it'll be
molecules in our body arranged as
information so I think information may
be the most fundamental way to describe
the universe and therefore you could say
we're in some sort of simulation because
of that
um but I don't I do I'm not I'm not
really a subscriber to the idea that um
you know these are sort of throw away
billions of simulations around I think
this is actually very critical and
possibly unique this simulation uh
particular one yes so but and you just
mean
treating the universe as a computer
that's processing and modifying
information is is a good way to solve
the problems of physics of chemistry of
biology and perhaps of humanity and so
on yes I think understanding physics in
terms of information Theory uh might be
the best way to to Really uh understand
what's going on here